in this video i'm gonna be breaking down
the seventh episode of attack on titan
season four in which the beast titan
challenged levi to a rematch
only to get butchered in front of his
fellow warriors and blown up with a
grenade
how embarrassing this video will explain
everything that i thought was
interesting about the episode
including the epic reveal of army's
colossal titan a very subtle throwback
to grisha's past
and of course aaron gaining the power of
yet another titan shifter
this man is literally the awful one of
attack on titan the way he's collecting
these powers one by one
before we get into it i do these reviews
every week so i'd really appreciate if
you hit the sub button
and of course let me know how you rated
the episode down below
i'll be giving my personal rating out of
10 at the end of the video so be sure to
stick around for that
okay so episode 7 was called assault
which is an appropriate title
considering the all-out war that
occurred
from start to finish it picks up where
we left off in the last episode with the
draw titan about to be destroyed by the
scouts
however before they can shoot their
thunderspears peak arrives at just the
right time
the panzer unit wipe out several scouts
with machine gun fire but luckily not
anyone we actually care about
at this time aaron is just casually
holding the crystal containing lara
tiber
but she launches a surprise attack with
the warhammer titan
the only thing saving aaron from certain
death in this moment was the fact that
he protected his neck with his heart and
forearm
otherwise he truly would have been toast
this final attack used up the last of
the warhammer titans energy
as in the previous episode she exhausted
herself by creating a ton of weapons
such as the hammer the sword obviously
the crossbow
and who could forget this giant spiky
pillar with no energy left the warhammer
titan had nothing to give from this
moment onwards but the beast titan was
nice enough to tag in for her
during the opening scene unlike peak and
porco who were trapped by that malian
soldier zeke was instead sent to the
front gate and it's still
unclear why we don't know if anything
happened to him once he reached the gate
but on his arrival to the battlefield
porco and most of the other soldiers
were pretty happy to see him
both mcgath and the kart titan
noticeably had nothing to say
about zeke's reappearance but by now
it's clear that they're both people who
are observant
and constantly questioning everything
moving on we finally got confirmation
that falco and reiner are alive
thanks to some quick thinking from the
vice captain throughout this series
we've seen how titans can partially
manifest for a specific purpose
like when aaron needed to stop that
cannonball or even earlier in this
episode
when the partial warhammer titan made
its final attack reiner did a similar
thing to say falco
by manifesting a gross amount of fingers
to protect him something which we would
never see in normal circumstances
and i personally hope we never see again
whilst falco was able to wake up
reiner remained unconscious because his
will to live at this moment
is noticeably low without a strong will
to live titan shifted injuries don't
just heal themselves automatically
and because you know falco saw the vice
captain begging aaron to kill him he
realizes why he hasn't woken up yet
as the scouts tried to avoid machine gun
fire and rocks being thrown at them
mikasa finds the way through and attacks
the warhammer titan with a thunderspear
the fact this has no effect on the
crystal shows that it's virtually
indestructible
and this is further proven when aaron
bites the thing only for his freaking
mouth to break
after biting the titan crystal eren
makes two realizations
number one is that he can't destroy this
thing by himself and number two is that
the warhammer titan is out of energy
he knows this because laura taiba is
still connected to the warhammer but she
made no attempt to pierce his nape
as he went in to bite with the attack
titan suspended in the air
aaron jumps out and manifests his third
titan of the battle
after the first one was decapitated and
now the second one is just out of
commission
polka seems stressed out by everything
that's going on but peak reminds him
that the battlefield is under marley's
control
as the scouts are in enemy territory
with limited fuel from peak's point of
view
the scouts have no hope of escaping but
obviously what she doesn't know
is that their escape plan was already
being set up since the last episode
the beast titan then directly calls out
levi to fight
seeking revenge for his crushing defeat
the last time they met
zeke makes it clear that levi is his
mortal enemy and not
eren which understandably surprises
everyone given the crimes that aaron has
now committed against mali
the reason levi checks his stopwatch in
this moment is because he's waiting for
the next phase of the plan to begin
but we'll get to that in a second as
falco makes it out the plaza
he runs into mcgath and gabby who just
arrived in the area
gabby's arrival is part of her one
person mission to kill eren yeager
seemingly with this ordinary rifle that
belonged to a security guard
yeah good luck with that falco informs
mcgath about reina's current state
before the scene cuts away to mali's
port as several ships prepare to dock
each of those ships contains many of the
soldiers that mcgaff ordered to blockade
liberio
but the scout's plan begins to come into
action as we see an unknown person just
chilling in this tiny fishing boat
they removed their hood and we can see
that it's none other than armin himself
who is just basking
in that titan electricity his mission is
to wipe out all the malian soldiers at
the port
and also to destroy the port itself
which is you know only a job that he can
do
you can see on arm's face that he's not
exactly happy about this as he generates
an explosion
so big that it obliterates the ports
sends warships flying into the air
and kills presumably thousands of people
remember that this is the same character
who vomited and cried when he first
killed a person and obviously back when
he was a kid
he was too principled to fight back
against bullies with violence
what he's just done here in this episode
is murder on a mass scale
which shows you that armin truly must
see no other option
than to do what he just did poco is
triggered by these events
as army's appearance confirms beyond any
reasonable doubt that bertolt has been
killed
which is something that marley suspected
but didn't actually know for sure
obviously buttock would have trained for
years with the other warrior candidates
so it's understandable why poco is so
angry at his death
he let his rage get the better of him
and decides that he can ruin whatever
the scouts are planning
if he kills eren yeager on paper this
logic makes sense but it was a bad idea
from poco for two reasons
firstly you can't get to eren without
getting through mikasa
and this time she whips out her swords
instead of the firearms that she was
using previously
the second reason this was a bad idea is
that by running off without a solid plan
poco left zeke and peak more exposed
levi takes advantage of the confusion by
sneaking up behind the beast titan
and dicing him up for a second time this
was yet another traumatizing moment for
gabby and falco
because they could only watch on as levi
detonated a grenade inside the beast
titan's nape
with this moment it seems that levi has
finally fulfilled his promise to erwin
by killing the beast titan also i
mentioned this in my breakdown last week
but gabby has witnessed so much death at
this point
that her feelings for revenge are
understandable but at the same time
what zeke and the rest of the warriors
did was also you know sufficient cause
for revenge
so both sides are not wrong in wanting
to kill the other
anyway as the warriors try to even
process seeing their captain get blown
up
sasha manages to get a headshot against
one of the panzer unit members
this kill is enough to divert peak's
attention and jean appears for a
surprise attack
blowing the card titan's face with a
thunderspear if you're wondering what
past moment jon is referring to as he
takes the shot
it was this scene back in season 3 when
the cut titan saved reiner
jon felt personally responsible for
allowing that to happen as hanji would
have already killed reiner by that point
if he didn't make her hesitate in the
present day the other scouts follow up
his attack
by blowing the cut titan to bits
alongside every member of the panzer
unit
the cart's body falls directly behind
gabby falco and magath
as if things couldn't get any worse for
them jean goes to deliver the finishing
blow
but a tearful falco becomes a human
shield and begs him not to fire
falco showed us when we first met this
character that he has no problem putting
his life on the line
for someone he loves or respects so this
action from
him wasn't a big surprise but what was
the surprise was the fact that jon
actually pulled the trigger
before we get into what happened next
with that the anime had already switched
scenes
to show us what was happening at the
port armin continues to walk forward and
crush
everything in his path but in terms of
the design of his colossal titan
in my opinion it's slightly meatier than
it looked in the manga
other notable features include his spine
being visible through his neck
and the lips being more prominent than
bertolt's armin notes that what he's
seeing right now
must be what berto witnessed all those
years ago as he then prepares to use his
odm gear to board the airship behind him
going back to jean he reluctantly pulls
the trigger which was a surprise
when you consider the kind of character
he is the shot does end up missing
and you know while it's possible that
jean subconsciously missed the shot
my personal take is that if the cart
titan didn't release this steam
the thunderspear would likely have made
contact and at the very least killed
falco
that's just what i think but let me know
if you agree or disagree in the comments
down below
anyway peak emerges from the cart titans
still alive as
more forces from parodies emerged from
the rooftops and tried to kill her
magath and the malian soldiers begin
somewhat of a fight back
which gives falco and gabby an opening
to take peek to safety
from porco's point of view he's not sure
whether zeke and peak are both dead
so he angrily charges at aaron with full
force in hindsight this was not a good
decision from porco
because in fighting against aaron he
accidentally showed that his draw titan
is perhaps the only thing on earth
capable of penetrating the crystal
his claws slice through the surface of
it which gives aaron a genius idea
what happens next is something that
needs a lot of explaining and don't
worry i will explain it
and that is the appearance of the
airship that was briefly cameoed earlier
in the episode
this ship is following the path of
lights laid out by the scouts
and on board is hanji armin this random
guy who i don't know
and this gentleman who is wearing the
uniform of the malian military
in a flashback during the episode last
week willie tiber said
the one thing he feared the most was the
traitors working with parodies
and he even admitted that many of the
traitors were in marley's own military
we already know willie was right because
obviously there was the soldier who
betrayed
peak and porco and now yet another
malian soldier
has aligned himself with the island in
the intro i mentioned that there was a
subtle throwback to grisha's backstory
and the thing i was referring to was the
scouts using this airship
during his childhood grisha's desire to
see the airship is what inadvertently
led to his sister's death
as they illegally left the segregated
zone to go and see it
the manga shows us that grisha thought
that only rich people could ride these
ships
and the eldians would never get the
chance because they would never be rich
that's why i thought it was kind of
funny to see that in the present day
at least one alien that grisha knows
personally is able to fly the ship and
fulfill that dream
even if it might be for the purposes of
war anyway the aim of their plan is to
follow the lights
and collect as many soldiers as they can
along the way especially aaron like he's
the main key
if they don't get him then they're
pretty much screwed using this ship was
armin's idea
and by destroying the port there are now
less soldiers available to shoot down
the ship
but still it was a risky strategy to use
a flying aircraft
poco makes a move to destroy it but
mikasa anticipates that he would do this
and slices off both his legs in the
process eren then quickly takes
advantage by catching the draw titan by
surprise
and ripping off both his arms so he
can't fight back this is complete
savagery from aaron and mikasa
but you know what it needs to be done
because the jaw titan's claws are just
way too dangerous to be kept on
aaron's genius plan then comes into
action as he shoves the warhammer
crystal into galia's mouth
knowing the draw titan has the power to
destroy it he lifts poco up in this
intense scene
as the crystal gradually begins to crack
until lara tiber's delicious blood falls
into eren's mouth
by consuming her spinal fluid aaron has
now stolen the power of the warhammer
titan
after centuries of it being within the
tibet family aaron is the first person
we're aware of to have three distinct
shifters in one body
but somehow this is not enough as he
then has the audacity to try and eat the
draw titan as well
he smashes poco's head into the ground a
few times even enough to damage the
armor of the jaw titan
and it's at this point that reiner is
the only warrior who can save the day
the vice captain was peacefully dying
underneath the rubble until gabby and
falco's cries begin to disturb him
it's clear he doesn't want to be woken
up and would much rather have stayed
there
but their noise becomes too much to bear
as he reluctantly transforms into the
armored titan
i imagine that rhino would have felt
some duty himself to save galliard
given that poco saved him during the
battle of force lava
episode 7 finished with reiner getting
up and i gotta say i
really enjoyed this episode a lot not
only was it action-packed but there were
some good moments of character depth
with jon and armin
as they kind of like wrestled with the
ethics of how far they're willing to go
to protect the people of parodies
aaron gaining the power of yet another
titan was also incredibly epic
so i'm going to give this episode a 9
out of 10 rating i'm one of those people
who doesn't really give out 10 out of 10
unless it's like an exceptional
circumstance um but no for real this
episode was really great
so 9 out of 10 is definitely deserved as
usual i'd appreciate if you dropped a
like if you liked this video
and share it with anyone who you think
might enjoy it thanks for watching as
always and until the next one
peace out